caldwell-pope and Danny Green those are  the two to me X factors for the Lakers  Anton Segundo another time and this is  good number 25 on the year in assists he  has not missed a game this season Yanis  from Korea what  look at this deep through here I mean  this is a couple of feet behind that  three-point line and he had just  previously the pep now and it's the hall  house started defensively for Frank  Vogel and the Lakers battle to the  triple look at this three here and this  is over length in David clock at three  great defense to here by Casey be  goodness four of six gets a jump shot  it's going to be lights out because he  has every other tool and that's at three  I would love for him to get a mid-range  game because I think a lot of vowels on  the floor onto the comb ball  [Applause]  looking like he's way out  [Applause]  while auditioning for the three-point  competition come all-star weekend five  of eight from downtown